how many bodies is too many bodies for a
girl one one
one what are you guys's body count zero
zero
zero that's crazy everyone i interview
is a virgin there are a lot of virgins
in london
i'm not from london so me too
um is sleeping around different for men
and for women it shouldn't be no it is
but it shouldn't be i literally agree
what she said like i'm saying yeah it
shouldn't be different but yes it is no
okay why why yes why now well no
i say it's different because of the
perception of people if you sleep around
as a woman you're a [ __ ] if you sleep
around as a man you're good what's the
basis of the question which is basically
what you said
you're saying it shouldn't matter it
shouldn't matter
yeah i say the same i'm just saying in
reality it does matter yeah in reality
what do i think
she will not say no i'll i'll tell you i
try to have conversations i mean i think
it does matter if you look at the data
like okay if a girl slept with zero
people and she's a virgin do you know
what her chances of having a happy
marriage eighty percent
if she's slept with more than five it
drops to twenty percent
so it's like when i'm looking at this
and this is self-reported how do i argue
with that go ahead where's the
statistics on that so it's a study that
was done in the u.s and and they would
they would ask women how what's the
what uk excited different so so they've
done they've done similar studies with
women on like other things like like
higher rates of depression higher rates
of like like
it all kind of goes together i think
body count matters i don't think it
matters it shouldn't stop me from like
wanting to be in a relationship with
someone but i do like look at it and be
like hmm like i do kind of no i don't
think it matters no timon is this just
what you're comfortable with what the
person is comfortable with so if it
doesn't matter would you guys say your
body counts yeah well mine's literally
one so there we go one and proud zero
yeah seriously crazy everyone i've
talked to is a virgin today
a version or three or less but it's just
the only reason i ask is because it's
like we say it doesn't matter but
oftentimes they don't want to say yeah
yeah no that's fair i don't care
i don't think it matters really i'm
transparent
like it's nothing yeah it's not a big
deal i don't think it makes someone like
less of a person at all i just i just i
just think like it's harder for women if
we've experienced more to be happy with
the one we have because we compare
that and i've seen a lot of girls like
where they're in love with their ex but
they're with the new guy what is your
personal experience with what
what um i get mixed answers some people
say it matters some people say it
doesn't i'm not saying i'm right or i'm
wrong it's going to change in five years
and what do you my my question
no i think it'll it's a more personal
experience
do i think it'll change what
you had
at some point yeah yeah yeah i have an
ex-boyfriend yeah yeah
um it was a couple years
[Music]
a couple years
yeah
i'm 25.
what
you were 23 when you had this
relationship
yeah yes okay yes
what that does it make you
want to ask that question and at this
point
people typically give me like more
honest answers have you been here before
i'm lucky to sleep around for this party
for sure
have you been here to the festival no
this is my first time i've never i've
never heard of it this is someone told
me about it i should do interviews here
without a doubt i think you should have
two out of three you have to attend two
years and that's the same question guys
we're gonna talk to a guy and he said i
slept with 50 women would you care no it
wouldn't matter
um
i wouldn't like make that stop me from
being with him but i would i think
because i'm very respectful about
sleeping people i'd be a bit like i
would probably go lower i would like
like if you gave me a reason why sort of
like was your mentality doing that was
it just to earn more women or was it
because you like them or sort of like it
just depends on the person well it's
kind of like you don't have the same
values in a way yeah yeah pretty much
overall though it's not a big deal but
if yeah it's the values thing yeah do
you think it's bad if a guy says he
doesn't want a girl that's slept with so
many people yes yeah i think that's bad
i think standards yeah if he's got if
he's also got a low body count and so do
i let's say i don't think it's a big
deal but if you stay with 40 girls and
then i've sat with like one guy you're
like oh i don't need to sleep with that
i think that's just stupid like yeah
that's right
do you think sleeping around is
different for men and for women both you
shouldn't be sleeping around that's
disgusting ill how many bodies is too
many bodies
i don't think body matters if you really
like the person i don't think body mind
you don't think it matters i don't think
it matters no what's your body
my body count body cows i can't really
say that
no the only the only reason i ask is
because a lot of times we'll say it
doesn't matter but no one ever wants to
say it no of course there was a state
but it doesn't really matter it already
matters if you're actually talking with
the person
and then you're out here doing [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay like you know you don't seem to be
doing that but if it was before you met
him you don't care or her i don't care
because i wasn't around
i wasn't around you know what i'm saying
so do you think it's okay for men to
care about that stuff
some men do but you know
i don't know i can't really answer that
question because you know i'm not a man
you know just a lot of times like girls
will say they shouldn't care but they do
so i don't care personally because i
didn't know you
way back before so it's like you know
what i'm saying but if you're in a
relationship with me or talking to me i
don't expect you to be talking to
someone else you know i mean like we'll
be doing stuff with someone else does
that happen dude i don't really care has
that happened body count has that
happened to me
no way
no i was just checking you just
mentioned it a couple of times no no it
hasn't happened to me no actually rate
yourself one to ten i'm a ten out of ten
what does the cameraman think
i'll rate you
oh i'll rate you all right i give you i
give you eight actually eight yeah
okay that's good that's good that's good
i don't i think 10 10 means you're
perfect i don't think you're right
i think i think you're like pretty
enough you could model but i think thank
you so
i want to give myself a 10 because self
love do you think that because i asked
this and this is like a common answer i
get today don't you think 10 means
you're perfect don't we all have room
for improvement yes well i think you can
always make room i think it counts do
you think sleeping around is different
for men and for women do you think
sleeping around is different for men and
for women oh gosh i mean definitely
because men can just go around and do
whatever they want then in the same time
we're all human
like i get it to a certain degree but if
you're a woman [ __ ] ten boys a boy
wouldn't want to go near her but if a
man did it
it would be fine actually i've
interviewed people on this today 10 is
right when you become not wifey it's
like at the 10 to 15 mark they're like
nah
just play but if it was a boy it'd be
different yes why i think women
i think when they do it it's more
emotional than when men do it i think
when men do it they're more thinking
about how they're going to feel
physically more than mentally and women
are more looking for an emotional
connection rather than something
physical i think that it is different
but it's starting to be
normalized that women can sleep with as
many men as they want to
just now i think within the last five
years with the rise of poly people are
more open to it but i think before yeah
it would be really different it would be
shunned upon how many bodies is too many
bodies for you to date someone
i don't think any really i think me i'm
not it should be
that wouldn't so do you think body count
matters if i'm not gonna lie to if i'm
being honest if it was really extensive
then yeah i'd be a bit slightly a bit
more cautious in that regard but i feel
you can't just judge on someone because
of their body count i just think that's